>> John: AND A DIFFERENT LOOK TO
BEGINN
TERAVAINEN, AND THE GAPS
OUT THERE.
ST. LOUIS BLUES MAYBE TAKING IT.
AND NOW STAAL TO THE
GOOD OPEN ICE HIT.
FAULK OFF THE
RAANTA.
AND HE MOPS UP THE REBOUND.
>> Jamie:
SCORED HIS 21ST OF THE YEAR THE
OTHER FOOT RACE FOR
JARVIS AGAINST COLTON PARAYKO.
AS WE W1:07.
2-0 HURRICANES.
NOW MIKKOLA BUMPED IN THE IN TH
VULNERABLE.
WE GOT IT H ANY
DEFENSIVE CORE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
HURRICANES FUNNELING PUCKS TO
NOW THE BLOUSE 4 ON 4.
>> John: IN ADDITION, THE BLUES
TOO, GET A GOOD BATTLE, NICK
LEDDY TAKESAVE BY HUSSO.
SVECHNIKOV AGAIN THEY DID IT
TWO OR THREE TIMES ON THAT
PART
HIMSELF SOME TIME AND SPACE PUTS
SCANDELLA IN A TOUGHN
THE ICE AND NO NOW
AROUND BACK FOR
>> Jamie: IF WE LOOK AT THIS
HERE,,
PARTIALLY TIPPED BY STAAL.
AROUND THE OUTSIDE NOW FOR
KYROU.
THROUGH
THEY'RE GOING BACK AND FORTH
PLAYING A LITTLE BIT OF
BORTUZZO.
AND THE BLUES DUMP IT IN.ON BY .
AND CHEAT ON THE PUCK TO TRY TO
CREATE SOME MORE OFFENSE. KNOCK.
STRIDE BY DeANGELO. SOME
PRESSURE, SUSTAINED ZONE TIME.
RYAN IT.
NOW FOR BUCHNEVICH, WAITING.
FINDS THOMAS ON THE HALFUCK IN
FEED IN FRONT WITH IT
IN TIGHT.
AHO, HEIS
THIRD.
THAT'S A REALLY TOUGH ANAN YEAR.
AND